j'ai commencé ma carrière en étudiant
les critères de décision en incertitude
radicale est l'un des rares critères qui
émergent c'est minimiser le maximum des
pertes quelques était guetté les pertes
maximales baisse et n oubliez pas les
modèles épidémiologiques projeter des
millions de morts donc si vous voulez
pourquoi puisqu'on ne connaît rien on ne
peut rien calculer on ne peut pas
calculer de dérivés secondes
quelle sera leur proche ce qui sera fait
au gouvernement vous avez précipité des
millions de morts dont brutalement la
santé publique passe au premier rang un
renversement complet du précédent et le
deuxième élément mais moi je suis
incertain
du coup ce qui va beaucoup impressionner
il ya un modèle d'épidémiologie
d'impérial collège caf pour le premier
un des modèles les plus utilisés qui a
formalisé ses modèles de diffusion du
coronavirus et tous les gouvernements se
sont entichés de ce modèle en disant
nous allons copier ce modèle et nous
allons copier les mêmes politiques les
autres parce que si moi je suis un
certain j'imagine que les autres ont
peut-être une information meilleure que
la mienne ce qui vous expliquent la
brutalité du mécanisme de confinement
c'est un grosso modo le confinement
pouvait se comprendre dans le système
chinois extrêmement autoritaire mais qui
eût cru que les français ces gaulois
résistant et aux changements techniques
accepterait ces éléments il a été
acceptée parce que le monde entier sait
que c'était la norme
il voyait à nouveau comme ans a
bouleversé la conception des théories
économiques
il faut prendre des décisions en évitant
de faire trop de bêtises mais à dieu
l'optimum optimum adieu les voyelles et
les subtilités de l'économiste andy un
traditionnel parce que on a pu les bases
les
les régularités se sont effondrés et il
faut prendre des décisions en tâchant de
minimiser
[Musique]